you were talking about kamza chamaya
feeding Alex pierra I've already won
five thousand dollars putting my money
on pahara now the question is I know
that we don't know what pajera's
wrestling's about comes that shamaya you
were betting on comms I said if they
fight Palms that take them down yes I
think hanza beats them stylistically
let's watch this clip this is incredible
he was talking [ __ ] yeah but Brad I
think he said that talk a lot of crap
that she might run over and blah blah
and also he's saying that he'll be able
to take Alex down 30 seconds he proposes
to do it back with y'all fifty thousand
dollars every Beach and those 50k from
both sides we donate kids that took
innate awesome 50 more
[Music]
[Music]
the fight
back at it again
[Music]
this is really the fighter in the kid
come on baby I've talked about this
before I if you guys are wondering why
my legs look like they can they can hold
both Mark and Brandon up it's because I
do the aerodyne bike now the assault
Fitness
she's saying legs but sure what my legs
almost fell off then you must have been
up like this yeah why how should I do it
most guys sit down and do this look I
did that I did all of it I did one
minute on women or off one minute on one
minute off Vince Lombardi said fatigue
makes a coward of us all I came in a
brave man I left the gym at coward
my legs were starting to panic I had to
sit down and go I'm going to panic
because I think my legs are going to now
if you if you want something tougher do
the Jacob's Ladder is that worse I don't
think anything's worse than the area
it's worse because it's a it's a it's a
it's a ladder yeah and you know you like
get a it's a what do you call it like a
crab walk almost yeah that
it's
awful yeah
Jackson's Ace of discipline us with that
and the aerodyne that aerodynamics all
day over that because that you there's
there's you can't the it's a belt so it
goes off your momentum So the faster it
just keeps going I Gotta Buy The Assault
Fitness bike and because I had the
assault I have the assault Fitness
treadmill I think I'm gonna buy that but
do I buy that or the Jacob's Ladder
that's a nightmare lesson I don't
believe he loves nothing I don't believe
that's harder okay what do I know
I got this
I could do it on aerodyne for it hold on
let me how long ago about 20. how long
have you done 30 years I've known oh
really it's been around forever really
we played did in football oh it's
terrible they're awful that ladder's way
now wait give me a Saturday I don't know
if you remember this but so when you
were doing when you were doing the
aerosol bike what was the uh like what
would you do one minute on woman off how
would you two minutes on one minute off
two minutes on sometimes I'm a uh
what was his freaking name uh John
chamber who's gsb's trainer and then
he'd come down to Denver and train us
yeah we would do it'd be a minute on 10
seconds off from it on 10 seconds off oh
no no you do rounds rounds and just line
up 10 seconds I get 10 seconds
awful it's so bad how long would you do
I forget who cares no yeah the answer is
always too I'm like the listeners right
now
the best sandwich I've ever had Subway
sandwiches dude man you get a cold cut
from them dude blow your mind now dude
aerodyne bike is a different thing yeah
they make even bulkier ones though
they're like I forget what they are they
there's like a battle one it's like even
thicker oh God it's like thicker more
resistance or something oh yeah you can
get an hourly with it it's so easy to
put yourself in like it's actually a way
to torture somebody if you really want
to get crazy or a great way to get in
shape yeah 100 100 yeah those are kind
of gay don't be surprised if Daddy is
it's not as it comes in here just ready
for whatever you throw his way you look
the same though yeah no no no
yeah they're a dime bike yeah there's
it's like the salt one assault Fitness
is the company yeah assault Fitness the
one that makes the big boy
this is straight A Salt Air Bike this is
a straight commercial Farm now yeah I
have this at my house you do yeah oh you
do have it do you do it you don't do it
it sits there uh right now it says there
yeah I'd rather get outside
because I don't have a fight coming up
you know yeah but they'll be a good
interest for you 700 bucks dude I'm
putting that out no you're not daddy's
gonna have a heart attack right daddy
almost had a heart attack I had to hit
the gym I was I was like I was like I
have to sit down right now because my
legs are starting
I was at uh uh um Bay Club great job Bay
Club the Bay Club yeah oh by you yeah
and uh wow were you filled with how was
how was Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving was good I went to our boy
Frank grillo's house Frankie yep had
myself a a wonderful wife what tasted
like a smoked chicken I like me a smoked
oh I love smoked chicken oh nothing like
it he smoked a chicken for you guys I I
don't think he did I think what he did
is he was bottled foods and bought it
yeah and in fact everything was bought
there but it was fun and we had some we
had oh he just did the whole food thing
but they had smoked chicken the whole
food I've done that it sucked oh man
whatever this was was delicious we did
the traditional turkey you know yeah
boring [ __ ] I was so boring give me
pheasant I want pheasant or smoked
chicken
it doesn't taste smoke but it's not I
think deep fries the the new deep fried
some Frank's Red Hot is the new
the new wave deep fry is not a bad call
bad call it's dangerous to do I heard
yeah because it can Splash up and
apparently not I mean it's freaking
turkey yeah but my girl my girl my girl
still made it pretty Mexican because the
World Cup was on so they had the World
Cup games on even though freaking the
NFL games were popping on Thursday it's
like what are we doing right now and
then the one next thing could you look
any more like a prototypical quarterback
there the other thing is is they had uh
you know there's my father-in-law making
the message he's a good looking couple
your father on your and and Joe's mother
but uh
the only Mexican thing they did is they
had tamales you had tamales yeah
the exact same they have net it could
have changed since they were invented
every she'll be she goes this is the
best Wives come from the street vendor
in Mexico but every tamale is the exact
same they're great it's not like they're
hey yeah all right yeah it's corn it's
mashed up corn and there's like red
sauce and chicken in the middle the
green ones are nice they make a sweet
one which I hate yeah they
the exact same every turkey is the exact
same so I did it best up with a a
Mexican Chef who was the first Latin
American Chef to win a Michelin star and
I was in I was in Chicago now he comes
from the south of Mexico and he said
he was he was broke his restaurant
wasn't doing well he gets on his hands
and knees he prays to God he just goes
help me because I got to go back to
Mexico this is a cooking I'm not a kid
and the cooking Gods the next day gets a
call and say you're the first Latin
American Chef to win a [ __ ]
Michelin star and I said well what what
was it and he goes I knew that people
had a concept of Mexican food which was
tamales tacos street food you know not
expensive yeah and he goes and I and I
knew the difference because my mother
when she would make certain things out
of corn or whatever it was [ __ ] that
would knock your dick into the dirt food
in the world oh dude I had I had his
food I got to tell you it was you know
me I'm a food guy you are too when you
go to Chicago
look it up chin what the [ __ ] is it
called you got to go there because it's
it's [ __ ] mind-bending no like
authentic mine boots on the best food in
the world oh my God you know the uh
even even their basic stuff be like even
like their beans and rice if it's done
right like correct Mexican rice I can
just eat a bowl of that yes but so no
but I know what you mean at the same
time I know what you mean when people go
this is the best it's a little bit like
yeah these are the best tamales you're
like
right but then again like tacos burritos
what we like quesadillas even burritos
that's not traditional that's American
that's like for Mexicans that's like for
the Chinese like orange chicken that
that's Americanization best stuff on
YouTube and you'll see it oh yeah is it
Restaurante ha no I did it I did a whole
thing it's my last one couldn't you just
type in uh Michelin star well the guy is
uh Carlos Gaetan yes Carlos Gaitan
Carlos Gaitan stud by the way 50 years
old looks sporty a ponytail built well
uh [ __ ] special guy man special
ponytail though
a handsome son of a [ __ ] and and
[ __ ] talented man
just one of those guys there he is yeah
dressed well you'd love him dude he dude
love him because his style his his he's
he's got great style like he's there he
is yeah he knows how to dress like he's
got those cool glasses yeah see I want
my Mexican Chef I want those wristbands
on those bracelets you want all that you
want an artist you want a [ __ ] artist
doesn't give much away at first then we
got into a conversation until you have
to you have to loosen them up yeah
because he's like who the [ __ ] is this
guy ease it in also he also he being
Mexican and being a chef there's a lot
of prejudice he didn't get the respect
he deserves really yeah man because the
the chef world is Italian's French it's
American when you're Mexican they're
like ah Mexican food there's a whole
there's a whole [ __ ] you know there's
a Prejudice to it in a way but not if
you're cooking Mexican food there is
because if you're doing if you're doing
this Mexican yeah if you're doing if
you're doing high-end Michelin rated
Mexican food people go ah you know but
you know you know you know uh what city
is just exploding as far as food goes is
Mexico City oh dude there's some like
the best restaurants in the world I
would love we should move to Mexico City
and do the podcast from there I set it
out it's not a terrible idea now we're
gonna get kidnapped by the cartel yeah
sure that might be so but they would
make you pit oh my God they put you in a
pit you think they'd have me fight bulls
and stuff no
no but first they'd go like this you'd
be like and they throw you out there and
you just be in like your underwear
you're like well and they'd be like
izuko Zuko I think anyway it's [ __ ]
phenomenal food
um and I'm old I'm very old and very
skinny so we gotta get some meat to my
face it's over it's over for Brian Kiln
let's move on I can't look at my face
um get my face out oh you know what you
appreciate is uh I went to the dentist
and uh because I grabbed my teeth I get
the shots in my jaw
oh to deaden the jaw well because I
grind my teeth so much it's supposed to
help so I don't break my teeth how do
you feel
it didn't hurt that bad can you feel
your jaw oh yeah it was a little sore
the next day but yeah they put the shots
in there three shots boom boom boom boom
boom boom you got some Invisalign it
won't matter if you grind because it's
just it's just rubber on rubber you know
what I'm saying yeah we gotta wear those
and you look like an idiot but so these
these though it loosens it so your teeth
can't grind as far I got five more trays
after this you know what I'm just saying
you've done it for five years I don't
give a [ __ ] at this point it's just
party I don't know just at this point
I'm literally used to it at this point
it's like it's like when you've been put
in prison and they let you out finally
and you're like I don't want to leave
this is my home no yeah you're you're
you're a man of the I want to stay here
it's it's yeah listener should be
institutionalized this is no we're going
to be getting some guests on this
podcast we've decided we're gonna start
we've been a little guest light a little
guest light and and we're gonna get some
guests on here so that's what you should
know now back to that that was a little
commercial break yeah um now I like that
you I like that you've shut your um you
shut your mustache down like you you
said that that's as far as you go oh
yeah can't keep going because then like
there's a there's a fire line yeah you
made a fire it gets too much I don't
know then it gets two watch I I wouldn't
mind seeing well I look like these Macho
Man Randy Savage is there a problem with
that yeah that's a good point you might
look tough as [ __ ]
why like macho man just get this going
and all of a sudden a few minutes you're
tougher than everybody you already are
tougher than that I don't want to do
that
why be a bully no we're a [ __ ] I'm
going to Providence Rhode Island and I
was texting my friend Steven goes they
have the most made men of per capita and
anywhere else in America I go yeah I
watch my p's and q's around and goes ah
these days I don't know but yeah I would
be head on swivel yeah don't you don't
maybe don't go up to people and go what
do you do you know yeah yeah no that's
the last hey have you seen Good Fellas
yeah that's the last stronghold of the
mafia apparently the Italian model I
heard you're a funny guy yeah funny
funny funny like what like a clown amuse
you yeah Brandon let me ask you a
question you take your digestion your
energy
taste nutrition you take all that
seriously dude I barely get a chance to
eat so I need something easy
multivitamin though listen to me right
now does that contain 75 vitamins one
tasty scoop contains 75 vitamins
minerals Whole Food sourced ingredients
you got a multivitamin you got a multi
mineral you got a probiotic you got
green superfood left you get your greens
uh and more and all of that you get in
one daily serving okay it's delicious
and uh it fills all the nutritional gaps
in your diet okay supports energy
supports Focus
um they've got the most reputable
ingredients and they go beyond
third-party testing it's my multivitamin
to make it easy after greens and give
you guys immune support and free one
year supply of vitamin D and right now
the winter December you need that strong
immunity baby you get five free travel
packs with your first purchase if you
visit athleticgreens.com fighter right
now again simply visit athletic
greens.com fighter to take control of
your to help and give a.g-1 a try listen
what buddy on it has a sale dude a sale
I see I need more energy they have these
sales
off supplements dude how about Alpha
Brain we usually give 10 off on it's
going to give you 25 off of brain ten
percent off Fitness Gear like steel Club
maces kettlebells the cooled bells 20
off nutrition protein bars 20 for your
bars barrels powder yeah all that fifty
percent off Digital streaming so you
want to get your thick butt in shape yep
you can do it from your phone and that's
the big 50 off that's that's right
that's 75 off supplements 10 off
vitamins 20 off nutrition 20 off gear 50
off Digital streaming workouts oh my God
on it.com right now use promo code
fighter save even more you're welcome
welcome to
special announcement coming in hot added
to rough and rowdy 19 December 9th I put
together one hell of a crew the talbas
fight companion show we will be watching
it live with the boys we're talking Theo
Vaughn Joey Diaz Rampage Jackson myself
[Music]
oh wow
what else you want tune in
you've never been to Providence huh when
I was when I was driving with Sammy the
book ravano and I said uh I was talking
about uh Jesse gas pipe casso who was a
horrible
tortured people probably tortured people
and I said did you know him he goes he
worked for me like he goes yeah he
worked for me and he knew him very well
I was like oh right those were your
cohorts you're my cohort you're my
co-worker Jessica
was his co-worker I was like right
sociopath right got you sociopath they
all are hey
gas pipe said I was really angry the guy
tried to kill me so then I had to you
know maybe I shot him
couple times the guy goes 15 times he
goes maybe I mean you know he goes he
goes I mean but but not until he died in
the legs and stuff he goes no no I mean
maybe maybe you know maybe 10 times he
didn't bleed out
no no gas pipe they tried to kill gas
pipe when he was with his daughter and
he got away that's nice yeah and then
they caught one of the guys
and uh he brought him down in his
basement
and
it wasn't a good death went to work on
him went to work on him wasn't a good
death Jesus Christ horrifying
when and gas pipe said well I yeah I I
took my time because so great was my
hatred
ah
but he's dead now gas pipe is still
alive I think gas pipe gangster Sammy
the bull tells a story so Gaspar was
still feared that you You released
another Sammy the bull thing is that
from the this is from the oh okay yeah
so so
um so how about this so so this is
actually a crazy story
so Sammy's talking about how they were
in they put the guys who turned on
State's evidence in protective custody
okay and gas pipe was one of those guys
in there or no he wasn't in there yet
but there was a guy there who had turned
on gas pipe okay so watch this so so
Santa
Anthony Anthony and he turns and he and
he turns to him and he goes he goes you
know gas pipe's coming in here right
he's coming into protective custody and
the guy
looks at her and goes
I guess like apparently what's wrong
I had a heart attack and died holy [ __ ]
he got so [ __ ] he he died right there
he's like he just [ __ ] had a heart
attack they go what the [ __ ] do you do
because I just told him that it's crazy
hey look at me maybe
we believe that one that's that's a
matter of fact that's a matter of fact
actually I died when he heard the name
that's actually well it was in it was in
prison so it was a matter of record
uh so he's still alive he's just serving
life in prison yeah
well no or he died in 2020. he he named
himself gas pipe after his father's
favorite rumored favorite weapon huh
has father been a captain of the
Genevieve's crime family his father had
a record for burglars in the 40s but
also worked honestly as a longshoreman
uh-huh and he urged Caso to stay out of
that life and said Casper admired his
father's past and named himself cast by
me he's the guy who said Being a
gangster On My Level is better than
anything it's better than being a movie
star a president anything probably for
about five years that's my stress well
did you see fear City when they talked
what what broke the mafia was the rack
was the RICO Act with the racket the
drugs the RICO yeah it was like well
that's like the what that what family
they never wanted to get into drugs ever
well yeah they knew that was again Carlo
Gambino I think was like but also even
the Gotti family and yeah Sammy talked
about a little bit gravana uh Gotti they
weren't supposed to get into drugs
either because they knew the feds were
cracking them
you don't want to touch drugs I think
God he was doing on the side yes yes
that's what royally [ __ ] him yes yes
that's right and then they put all the
top guys The Syndicate in jail for over
100 years three men in their 30s and a
woman a woman
and two men in their 30s they they were
like in their 30s and they they had to
they they basically took and Giuliani
Rudy Giuliani was like let's go it's so
stupid it's like you get how much money
like even when you look at Pablo Escobar
are you talking about back then eight
eight billion dollars cash yeah why keep
going because it's the juice but but
how's someone uh hey dude come here just
take say you want to hear it you wanna
hear a really [ __ ] interesting theory
on this that I thought was fascinating
so I had a guy named um on my podcast
the Brian count show I had um uh [ __ ] uh
Stephen Cutler he said he's uh flow he
studies um he's one of the foremost
experts on performance Peak Performance
aging and also below so like they're
getting low State yeah
and you say Alpha Brain ten percent off
trouble code fighter yes getting the
Flow State yes
um and he has a really really
interesting sort of like Book on a
number of books on this book into the
flow yeah really fascinating guy and
really fascinating science so juvenile
juveniles juvenile delinquents who have
very unstable homes
um
will they do graffiti
they do crime you know they they drive
too fast what are all these things that
happen when you're right there's no
supervision right
they've done some really interesting
research on what they're actually
addicted to is it's the one time they
have stability because it's the one time
their brain shuts off it's the one time
the heightened experience puts them so
in the zone they actually get in a flow
they're addicted to that zone and it's
the only time that they don't feel
anxiety anger Insanity they're just
doing something that's extreme that puts
them into the state of flow couldn't
they do something else to get them in
that state they could but they haven't
been getting granted that option yeah so
career criminals right so you have
career criminals yeah uh whoever it
might be it's the only time they get
into something like flow when you're
robbing a museum of the art or you're
you know you're committing uh crime
that's big
you don't have time to think of anything
else you're literally in it's like being
so so uh he Stephen Cutler did something
called
um
uh Park scheme where he was doing all
these jumps and all this crazy [ __ ] now
you stopped doing that at 35 years old
he said I'm going to try it at 53. I'm
actually going to hire some of the best
coaches and he had the money and he goes
I'm going to try to become this person
why because he wanted to see when he did
something really dangerous
um what it did flow wise it put them in
that flow state and again he's a guy who
said I he studied this he goes I'm gonna
actually I'm gonna actually he's one of
those guys who goes let me see if I can
do this I want to actually do what I
write about by doing learn how to surf
by like base jumping yeah so we learned
how to surf learn how to rock climb
learn how to how to um he's an expert
skier or anybody but learn how to Parks
key really in shape guy like that but
but my age but stays in shape yeah but
it was really interesting because he he
said when you actually do something
that's dangerous that you could really
get [ __ ] up over you forget everything
yeah and then that's what gets you
addicted to it and then all of a sudden
everything you do is around that so why
do why do like you see a lot of this
with like remember heat and they were
like these big time criminals that [ __ ]
those people they don't it's like it
doesn't it has nothing to do with the
money absolutely that's the juice you
want to really [ __ ] them over give them
all the money and tell them they can't
do anything yeah they'll go crazy so
it's the juice and and a lot of us had
that I mean I certainly think comedy
comedy fighting Fighters because look at
Connor and look at Floyd like why does
Floyd keep doing it it's the juice the
attention it's the flow you get in the
flow man look think about why why do you
I wonder if flow is the same uh I wonder
if that's the right
definition for it right because
yeah because for Fighters it's more of
like an intent like you're getting
attention it's like the system going
into it they used to think comedy they
they think you you you so when things
slow down you know you've had these
experiences
um they just think that you were using
more of your brain what they think now
is that when you get into the zone or
the Flow State you actually are using
less of your brain 100 right you're not
thinking you're in the moment you're in
the moment yes did you feel that did you
get that information once in my life
yeah Gabriel Gonzaga fight really
interesting Gabriel Gonzaga what
happened you just could do no wrong
there was so much pressure on the fight
and I remember because Shane beat him so
he lost the Dos Santos lost a shame it
was like my first test he's right like
12 12th in the world I remember going to
the fight I was a guy if I don't win
this fight I'm just gonna go do
something else because I don't want to
be just a guy and people gotta know
Gonzaga was a [ __ ] monster back then
like nobody had leg kicks like that look
at him there God damn he threw a leg
kick and I just popped him he was so
experienced too and he just had he was
so experienced I only had six fights at
the time I remember I was like if I
don't beat him I'm just gonna stop Jesus
and I beat it was good for me at the
time too I beat him uh three round
decision lit him up
um but I remember walking after I felt
so much pressure but that was the only
fight where yeah to your point that flow
state it was like uh
that's a big you you remember in
Spider-Man when uh that Bully's like
throwing the punches yeah and it's like
going slow that's what it felt like I
was like you're so sweet wow I was like
you're so screwed wow yeah everything
through I was like get out of here damn
yeah
that's an incredible feeling man that's
like can you imagine spot being able to
bottle that and turn that on whenever
you want yeah you can't yeah yeah that'd
be cool other than that no but I'll get
on stage sometimes
where if you know you're set so well
you're like in that flow state where
everything's 100 boom boom boom boom and
then you're adding tags yes sometimes I
get off stage I'm like oh gee you know
you have like it's almost like a trance
I know it's almost like trance it is
it's almost like when Will Ferrell
remember on uh was it um Wedding
Crashers was it Wedding Crashers oh no
it's uh is that the movie remember what
happened where he he's like I don't have
a blacked out he's debating he's
debating the the Raging Cajun yeah he's
like the dumbest one yeah yeah oh no
it's uh old school it's on there because
Jeremy Piven right and they're trying to
screw him over
so they keep their fraternity on campus
so they have a debate against the Raging
the old schools and remember he go he
just says all this outlandish like
really smart [ __ ] and he goes what just
happened I don't know what happened like
holy and you beat them yes that's like
that's sometimes you'll get off stage
I'll look at my brother I'm like holy
[ __ ] man that's nice and everything's
just firing popping you on tags it's
like man if I could have just recorded
that so I remember the tags that's
exactly what it is yeah it's strange for
complicated Apes the second show is that
way not my first show the second show in
fact Justin came down and he just looks
my agent goes holy [ __ ] I go I know dude
I felt it I was in I was like I didn't
have to think about it it was just like
it was it was doing it was natural yeah
but that that's what everybody talks
about in general if you're if you know
they say people like Jeff Bezos and
stuff when they're doing business when
they're thinking and they're working
through something it's the same thing
they get in the flow so you know I think
with anything you're doing like you
you're when you're in college or you're
like writing an essay sometimes I'm just
sitting there like Jesus Christ man yes
and sometimes you're just going going
knocking it out that's it not on the
Adderall or anything that's why writing
like that's why um I told you about
stuts which is anybody who's who watches
Netflix watched Jonah Hill's
um amazing documentary he he has a
therapist Jonah Hill lost his brother
anybody who watches Netflix yeah he lost
his brother
um and he he'd been in therapy for a
long time but he found this guy Phil
Phillip Stutz s-t-u-t-z
I watched this I've watched it twice I I
don't know maybe other people won't feel
like you know what is Schultz talked
about I felt so [ __ ] it was so moving
so beautiful and this guy has figured
out a way to
um
he's figured out a way to create tools
to help you through your life
um and man I oh okay so he co-wrote the
book the tools I'm gonna read it that's
what you were saying right Mark I'm
gonna read this book it's called the the
uh and and he talks about the tools
um and I I got to tell you man at 55
like a lot of times I see stuff I'm like
I've seen it I know I don't know this
was so new to me and look on that
article one of the things he talks about
is here's the thing about life you'll
never Escape think about life New York
Times one yeah right there yeah
it's so good man I'm out of mind and he
and and Phil Stutz has Parkinson's
so he has to deal with that
uh when he was nine he lost his brother
when he was three Jonah lost his brother
um he lost his brother to what I don't
know find out how Jonah Hill lost his
brother he wouldn't talk about it
because his sister is a big time actor
too oh I didn't know that yeah he's so
talented and they went to uh Harvard
Westlake oh wow
sudden blood clot blocking and artery in
his lungs wow it was three no no his
brother was older last December
oh
yeah he just died uh Jesus Christ
manager I wonder if it was from Cobra or
something
click on that chin this is John Hill
brother the link
man
yeah his brother took a photograph of it
remember Bubba hey his brother takes the
day he he died his brother died his his
therapist goes give me your phone he
took a picture of him and he goes I want
to take a picture of you at your lowest
point remember I did that to you yeah
Travis Brown I met you out at
groundworks yep I said give me your I'm
going to take a picture of you at your
lowest point I wish we had that picture
we'd do somewhere I'll find it it might
be on my phone you're like this
yeah waiting you posted it I think I'm
sure yeah and I was like I'm gonna take
a picture of you and your what year was
that point huh what year was it whenever
the trash Brown fight was to him 14. I
didn't go through it fine because it's
on your screen it might be 2014 yeah
let's find it I don't know if I had
Instagram then
oh no it's all the way it'll be a while
yeah no you did it's gonna be easier to
go through my phone chin I'll go through
it all right I'll find it it's a long
one it's Jesus Christ but uh it was
great and he said you need a visual for
where you are so you can see the
progress you made you know but he said
there are three things you'll never get
out of in life for everyone I don't care
how talented you are I don't know how
successful you are I don't care who you
are said one is pain in one way or
another you deal with pain you're always
going to deal with pain oh like you
can't control it like you're gonna think
it's gonna come to your life
two is uncertainty
I assume a pain meaning like heartbreak
all that all of it whatever it is okay
uh two is two is uh uncertainty you know
you can't predict a few no three is
constant work
you got to work oh yeah and and once you
realize that and then he talks about
something called part X which is
um no matter who you are no matter who
you are
doubt anxiety
fear depression uh the voice that tells
you what you want is impossible you
can't do it you're not good enough all
those things it never goes away I assume
it never goes away no matter how do I
get rid of it because you can't but know
that it's there no that that that that's
a cloud that the sun is always there but
sometimes a cloud is blocking the sun
it's when you think the cloud is never
going to go away but he said once you
understand it part X
is not something you can
um part X is not something you can uh do
away with but with it comes opportunity
and if you if you can look at it as
opportunity not as an obstacle it's how
you start to do things but here's what's
really important here's what's [ __ ]
fascinating so Stephen Cutler who writes
about flow and wrote this book called in
our country about uh being a a you know
uh skater a skier he said anytime you
want to accomplish something especially
later on in life and and [ __ ] stuff
said this too you need forgiveness you
got to be able to forgive the people
that are that that you're angry at in
your past or forgive the people that
[ __ ] you over in your past or forgive
whatever it is or whoever it is that you
think did you wrong if you don't do that
both of them said this both of them said
that and there then he is he gives you
tools for how to do it which I thought
was [ __ ] fascinating but if you don't
do that man you will never you will be
stuck in blame and you'll be stuck here
saying [ __ ] these people and it will
block your creativity and it's something
I've been thinking a lot about and and
uh it makes total sense but you don't
have any of that DB
I I have less of it than most people but
I certainly have a lot of you have a
reason to have it yeah I have I do you
understand I almost don't I mean I think
I could learn so much from seeing this
no but you're pretty good at moving
forward the best yeah and I was I don't
I guess born like this maybe my dad
instilled it when I was little I can you
know the sports uh reference I didn't
throw an interception I don't even think
about it yeah you have amnesia you've
been taught to have amnesia next play
next [ __ ] play because if you're
thinking about the last play you're
[ __ ] yeah and I don't train to be it
but I also don't I don't hold any
resentment like even people that you
name it man people that I'm sure the
fans like I bet Brandon hates him or her
not at all no I know I don't even think
about them if I do I talk positive about
them well part of that is like whoever
is out there and if you're spending a
lot of time hating on people man
um it really does it's really a bad
technique for getting ahead it I'm just
telling you it doesn't work right I've
had to learn that and I I fall
anybody yeah but we all fall into it we
all fall into it but but but
um it's really really unhelpful it's
really I always tell a story about when
I would always be criticizing people in
my acting class they'd be getting up and
I'd love to sit back and [ __ ] with them
what are you doing when I was there when
I got on stage that same critic started
[ __ ] with me I started doing it to
myself you can't get away from that
so moving forward like like no time for
just a waste of time man there's no time
to be blaming people or be mad at people
that's why Revenge but but even even
to debate it online like say a hater
leaves a comment like you don't fire
back to the haters I'm like no no
because that takes away time for what
I'm I don't know that's not going to
achieve anything
it's not going to get me to where I'm
trying to go and I know people that that
like you know Donald Trump is known for
uh loving Revenge he loves to get
revenge now if you're that guy that's
fine well I don't I don't do the problem
when you're fueled by revenge and to be
honest when I first started podcasting
comedy was like a a f you to Dana White
right because people say you have a chip
on your shoulder I had a stack of
Pringles so it can be a motivator but
then you eventually you run out of that
gas like I'm not doing it for them well
it doesn't sustain just help me get this
it's nice it's a night look I know very
successful people that that have written
great movies and done great movies
because of Revenge
I want name names but I know some
successful [ __ ] uh writer directors
in the world who were like I was like
what made you write this movie and he
was like Revenge everybody said no to my
[ __ ] sequel yeah I was like wow okay
and then the different type of events
too right well I'm sure Clapton might be
saying this like when cop got cut from
the NFL the Buffalo Bills they send this
letter like basically basically you're
not good enough to play that thing's in
his in his closet framed smart so he
sees it every day and you know he's well
that's wildly successful Hanzo has in
his in his doge in his studio in his
Academy he's got a framed picture of
when sakuraba broke his elbow and and
it's like what are you doing he goes I
wanted to be able to see what never to
make that mistake yeah well but then
there's also the Revenge thing you think
about Michael Jordan the best ever do it
you know I don't know if he's happy I
don't know he makes a billion dollars
off his shoes most successful
businessman you know of all all-time
professional sports we can talk about
the Jordan brand people say uh Lebron
you know billionaire who's active but
Jordan's really you know he's worth
billions upon billions with Jordan
even you know you're talking about your
Hall of Fame speech he was talking [ __ ]
to his high school basketball coach but
it's amazing and it's not that's amazing
it's like holy [ __ ] yeah that's a guy I
would say that that chip or that sort of
motivator is helps him like so Nick Diaz
used to always say I gotta hate the guy
I'm fighting and I got to come up with
some reason to hate him otherwise
certain guys do yeah and that would be
different so whatever works for you now
you don't want to hang out with them no
but also you're gonna have all the
success like Kobe's so competitive you
don't want to hang out I would say he
but Jordan uses so I would say Jordan
uses revenge like that resentment as a
tool yes he doesn't use it to hold him
back he's not dwelling on it he goes you
said no it's feeling them watch yes
watch yes [ __ ] I'm part of that
yeah
okay yeah all right yes but uh
anger no I don't have anger I'm sorry oh
wow yeah like the doubt is what does it
well I kept a letter that my mother sent
me from her one of her dearest friends
saying I'm very worried about Brian
being an actor because I don't think
he's ever going to make it it's like
unless he's insanely talented the
chances are and I kept that letter I
read it to my acting class after I got a
big job I said to anybody who's like you
know because for me I was like oh I'll I
never let go I still have that letter I
was like okay cool I like that but I
didn't dwell on it I used it as
motivation no yes fuel that's kindly
yeah there's difference yes but but like
revenge is a different thing like um
uh Confucius has a great quote before
you seek revenge remember to dig two
graves um
because you're going to put yourself in
a type of grave too yeah it's just not
healthy doesn't it doesn't work more
importantly it doesn't work
it doesn't work I would eat you up from
the inside Daddy went to church on
Sunday alone no because my baby was
asleep so I didn't want to wake him I'll
we were just bored out here my girl my
girl grew up going to church though no
uh I went to church because my buddy uh
Catholic Church yeah my buddy invited me
no it was uh it's not it's like a it's
like a it's a Christian church but it's
like they play music it's a little new
age it's like Hipster Church yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so for me I was like I'm
just sitting there like I I went just
because my buddy said come and I was
like ah you know I don't mind I like
checking it out seeing what all the
hype's about the bishop said something
interesting said something pretty cool
oh you're listening yeah he talked about
I was I really was because it's very
long well at first there was a band up
there and they were singing Christian
songs and I'm listening singing along
everybody's like you know singing along
and they're doing this and I'm thinking
to myself I'm listening to this it's
good music because they're actually a
really good band very in tune catchy can
you ever cross over that Christian like
rap or Rock like that dog it's not the
guys like put your hands up oh man I
enjoy them we're gonna be like these
lyrics are today but I enjoy it yeah you
feel like you're right that's a horse in
slow motion
song because things slaps and they were
great but then be like Jesus oh wow I
will always open my heart everybody's
singing along because the lyrics are up
there oh and you weren't singing no no
no I was like this I'm like looking
around going uh like this is this is
annoying me a little bit because it's
it's very nerd at the party you're the
with his back against the wall while
everyone's having a good time you're too
cool for school I'm too cool for school
because a lot of times if you look at
this new Christian Revival among young
people the the uh the the preacher is
hip as [ __ ] he's dressed like you oh
that's why I stopped going oh it's no
that you just better remember I was
going that one in LA with Tim Tebow
right the guy flew in on private jet
came in he had Yeezys on so you know he
had like [ __ ] like his tailored like
is he the guy got in a little bit of
trouble for having sex with some of the
mistakes okay and I remember I went to
dinner I was like I what is going on
here and then the the moment that
changed my brain when I they're talking
about gay stuff like that and I said uh
and then they were talking about you
know people converting to Christianity
and Jesus saves and all that I'm like
that's going on I was interested in it I
still wasn't that religious I was just
interested to see how it worked and I
would go so hold on my dad and brother
they're uh they're not Christian he goes
he was like
I'm like what you know how defensive I
give my brother and Daniel what he was
I'll never forget that cheesecake and
Beverly Hills hey what's that he goes
you don't want to hear this man but
anyone who's not Christian you know they
go to hell I go who said that the
homeboy and I go and right then I was
gone for I'll never come back yeah
because you're out of your [ __ ] mind
hey you and then I went to see you and I
went well what about like the the people
that are born gay like some people are
straight born like that like these are
facts like some people are born that way
man he was unless they find Jesus man
it's gonna get tough and I was like oh
all right I'm out man
but that's that is that is one of the I
think that's been perverted I don't
judge misses the point of Christianity
of course but
um bring up see if you can find that
preacher that guy he was I I said I
don't know is that his name John Chris
or no no he that's a comedian but wasn't
he appreciate before I'll look um but
you know
so Theo knows him too so I don't
interrupt you Theo knows him too I don't
think he's a bad guy no he's not at all
he's actually a really good guy made
some mistakes right you know so people
make mistakes but he um
proponent Justin Bieber's guy come up
but um so we brought him up on uh King
the Stinger because Theo did something
with them and we brought him up and I
you know on that show the the origin
that show we clown people and I was like
yeah I forget what I said like [ __ ] boy
something like that dude
Carl the net Carl Lentz dude the next
week I'm at a hotel in Newport with my
family and he's there next door to us
and I walked out and he was like how are
you doing I was like you could tell like
he was like how are you doing I was like
oh and I could tell because you had gone
bad on him lit him up you know that's
what we did he was like laughing like
dude you're going to hell I was like
maybe he'll be right there with me you
know just like making jokes he heard it
it got to him it went viral and uh I was
like hey man just so you know you know
on that show I don't see the clip like
it's all jokes dude everybody gets it
nobody's safe he's like no no no it goes
I was like I'm going to hell aren't I
he's like you absolutely are but he
didn't say that but Bill it's Bill well
he's a stud boy super stun boy uh
Justin's a little guy that was years ago
though Justin's bigger now but he's
studying his fashion was on point I mean
I wish I knew his stylist was yeah
um look he's he's uh but he would he
would get up there and preach like that
yeah I had like dude you have a u-neck
on and you have a chain and you know
you're cooler me and you you they're so
worried about their looks came in a
private gem like what is happening
that's a lot that's a lot and and he and
my the preacher at this thing was
talking about
um basically said there are a lot of
charismatic churches and it's all good
but let's not forget what we're here for
you know but again I don't have a
problem him relating to you I'm very
happy with this build oh time let's
start there dying handsome dude are you
kidding me right now handsome I started
wearing glasses just because of him I
would wear glasses no I didn't mean I I
did not look like I mean he wins oh he
wins in every facet and probably a great
guy and and you know he probably had sex
with some he's very good looking so you
can imagine I would imagine a lot of
women like him and I guess what did he
do have sex with some of his followers
is that what happened uh a lady in the
church I guess if you came out and then
it became a thing he was married you
know yeah okay nobody's perfect I mean
he but he's uh it's that Hillsong how is
he doing by the way is he back on I
don't know here's my thing like my
interactions with him besides the weird
you know but also that I don't judge him
um his weird theory on if you don't you
know submit yeah that's not an uncommon
not your book and that's fine but um
they're so judgmental but again I don't
I even I didn't judge that he was a
super nice guy though man really really
nice guy
but again I don't know is that a front
like I didn't know him that well like I
would go there I remember I go there you
know I'd dress how I normally he was
unfaithful to us which is nice now and
they're saying he was disgraced but not
them I didn't dress like them I'd go
there Selena Gomez they're just the
Who's Who and I realized oh this is more
of a networking thing for these people
like it's an event yeah I'll say I'ma
stop going and then I said my dad I'm
really going to Hell's like
oh I'm definitely out because they're
better people than you right and they're
way less judgmental
okay so he's falling a hard time
that's a pretty hard oh why'd they do
that former La home current Florida home
grass is all dead it's put on weight
grew his hair out to look like Jesus
yeah he went through a lot I guess but
uh oh he lost everything dude once and
he had it what he did was he had a fair
on his wife it looks like yes and then
they see the lady out of favorites no
okay well
uh even Jesus might do that let me let
me take a look even juices
when you get into heaven Jesus would go
like this I get it give me a hug like
she's yeah dying piece yeah and I don't
want to I I hate bringing all this stuff
up no okay we won't show it on camera
yeah she's uh yeah she's very attractive
and sometimes a man slips I mean
okay
again if you're that good looking and
you're gonna and you're gonna be that
charismatic and you're in L.A but that's
awesome yeah
four kids too his wife Dime Piece too
unbelievable now the guy's killing it um
and they came after that anymore but the
thing is is um two is uh yeah I feel bad
for him personally in general I don't
know
I think you should lose your entire life
over a mistake having a marital mistake
can we repent father I was gonna say
what's happening
I can't get my dicks why ain't easy we
can't repent this but I'll say this I
this is someone this is the long and
short of of something I got from church
I got this oh sorry okay
yeah because he was talking about he
goes I have to guard my own heart when I
read about the abuse that priests have
done and he just I just read an article
600 people came out and these these
these uh people who said they had been
abused by by when they were kids by
these priests uh different priests
Boston yeah all so many and he said I
have to guard my own heart
and I said I don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on but that doesn't and he's
talking about the Holy Spirit
and he said it doesn't mean you can't
take the spirit in your own heart right
and and he used a really cool metaphor I
thought that was really a really cool
metaphor said
um when there are people that can take a
piece by Mozart and play it note for
note perfectly but then he moves on it's
all good no they play it it's all good
and it sounds what it sounds like right
then you get a [ __ ] like Yo-Yo
Ma he said get Chuck now or you get
shock Perlman or one of these guys who
are Masters on the on the violin or on
the cello and they play it
and you go holy [ __ ] the difference is
well you know Jen the difference is
astonishing yeah and it's almost like
that's the difference between like he
was putting his talent his spirit
and everything in that piece so though
you so it's like you can read scripture
and then you can read scripture like
it's it's the idea behind there is
something else in in belief what's this
have to do touching little boys
that's that is I'm talking about outside
faith I'm talking about how like no
matter what undeniable Faith uh to be I
I respect I wish I had it and I did grow
up going to church I wish I back then
when you're a kid you really don't know
like my grandma before she passed away
she was so excited to die she's like oh
I can't wait it was like your birthday
yeah so I can't wait I'm finally gonna
meet my Lord and Savior I'm like holy
[ __ ] yeah that's good for you I would be
sobbing
oh my God I don't who knows what's next
well being an atheist you don't have
much to fall back on I'm not an atheist
yeah I'm not an atheist I know at all
but you know well my grandma I was like
man I was jealous I'm like holy like you
you thought you know the Denver Broncos
win the Super Bowl again she was so
excited she said I'm so ready man she's
like oh why did I wake up again wow I'm
like holy [ __ ] that's cool were you
talking about well she died almost at
100 years old 100 years devoted that's a
long time to wait the vote they say the
Queen of England was that way she was
incredibly religious and couldn't wait
it must be comforting especially if you
TR if you straight up truly believe that
like if you die you go to a better place
yeah think how excited you would be my
grandmother on my other side and it's so
sad I grabbing on my [ __ ] cancer
and she was like she was talking about
yeah you know apparently with the heaven
stuff and she goes if there is a heaven
right yeah it's like cute gangster
badass she was just like
I mean Christopher Hitchens he was a
massive atheist and he got throat cancer
and was religious dying no no oh really
no he goes I'm at the front of the race
here and I'm but they said do you do you
does it change it you're he goes no not
at all not at all I was like okay yeah
there's something about that the most
scariest time in my life I've prayed man
I was like listen I know I'm not I know
I've been doing what everybody else does
to be in the club but dear God help me
here and it you know I found my son had
those seizures I was in The Green Room I
never forget it in Salt Lake City I got
down my hands and knees threw him so I
had to go on show sobbins not bubbles
uh Keith was like hey dude you sure you
wanted to show him like I'll figure out
some of the shortest joke because I
gotta get out of here he's like man if
you if you want they'll understand I'm
like no no I'll go out there give me a
second I was sobbing on my Anthony I
remember I remember rain dude I'm
talking I'm praying for an hour I was
with you when you got the call my god
dude
um
well that's unbearable no I mean it's
unbearable sir no
yeah yeah yeah I know yeah I told my
girl I mean thank God we have another
one but I was like man
I'm out
she's like you're making it worse I'm
like I'm out man I'm telling you he's
not okay I'm I'm out man there's no way
yeah dude yeah um we're getting deep
on T fact okay just passes out
yeah
we talk heavy dude we talk father
yeah if you gotta deal with like if you
believe that like the exorcism or some
[ __ ] you you can get religious real fast
if you're if you're flying to Naples
that plane starts to go down you're
getting religious real fast real fast
you be praying to God Carl lenses by
your side you know yeah man like hey do
the say the whatever the script okay
Carl and start his own like thing again
somewhere come on bro I don't know how
it works because once you're out you're
out right because like that comic that
comic who's a phenomenal comic what's
his name
uh John Chris John Chris so he got
kicked out right because he did he was
giving tickets to girls trying to hook
up with them which is frowned upon where
the comics would do that so uh headliner
successful kind of do that it's
outrageous but there he is he's a big
guy September 14th his last post stays
in shape still stay in shape looks like
he's with this family still so I hope so
God forgives dude God forgives look at
this beautiful family you know what I
would do if I was him I would dude be
like babe I woke up Jesus talked to me
and was like we gotta stick this out
he's all right man
yeah we'll work through it might be good
for him you know what now I can live his
truth does he not does he not post
anymore or something or is that a last
time that was the last time so the
September what 14th was the last time
okay you know what I'm saying like you
can live Your Truth like that John
Christ I I know he's a great comic but
imagine being that clean of a comic and
you have to be that clean you can't you
know he's a calm he's a real comic so
you kind of want to get dirty but you
can't because you got your your you know
pigeonholed is this that's tough when
you're when you're accomplished and then
when you start living your truth I bet
his I bet his stand-ups never been
better uh-huh just fire uh
yeah
remember okay let's uh went to the worst
post that's okay I'm just looking at
where there's a girl I don't know why
congratulations what are we doing over
42 million views that's it special 42
million views what
that's incredible my last question what
do we do on the power of social media is
truly wild I was like I bet if we just
put on YouTube and clip up all my social
media platforms people like you can
share it it's like what happened is he
combining everything either way that's
awesome nuts yeah I mean that's insane
let's get him on the podcast that's not
a bad idea yeah
what if he said you guys don't believe
in Jesus Christ I do like hey man I'd
love to have a conversation about
religion with him actually
uh where is he is he in L.A I have no
clue oh look at him John Chris hit us up
we want to talk to you we should
probably hit him up yeah we'll hit him
up
Nashville love it
but he's in Irvine on
December 2nd to the 4th
I'm in uh I'm in Naples
yeah let's hit him up love to get him on
to see what happens wow
wow good for him
yeah
oh yeah
but it must be what a relief too right
if you live in a
like who was that comic uh
our boy oh preacher Lawson because he
blew up on uh America got's Talent right
he like blew up on there but you got to
be really clean on there so people go to
the show and he's not all clean like
whoa what happened to like [ __ ] that
was for ABC
he started fighting you handsome
[ __ ] he's hilarious yeah
he's talking about he can't go to prison
because he's a butt he's like I'm
screwed man I go to prison look at this
butt stood up he does have this like
giant bubble butt yeah I'm screwed I
can't go to prison yeah he's a good
looking dude he's so cool guy yeah
another guy he moved he moved to New
York
oh he did yeah because I was helping him
with uh his fight stuff oh okay yeah
he's great and he's taken it pretty
seriously there huh I think I mean yeah
he's athletic dude he's messing around
but obviously comedy's just like do you
hear Do you hear uh [ __ ] Whitaker
talking about Pera
sounds curious he goes [ __ ] guy's
huge but he wants to fight him I mean
he's like he's so big though he's like
his head everything I don't [ __ ] let
this guy get get down that low Pierre
said he's scared of oh Sean Strickland
so he's the most terrified before they
fought before they thought he was he was
cool like when you talk all that stuff
and stuff he said but once we get on the
Rock gun the way he looked I was like
holy [ __ ] this is a different dude
crazy dude oh yeah gets in there he's
there it's a fight for him it's not a
sport it's a fight oh it's life or death
yeah I was telling chin on uh sharp show
like he's like Josh Barnett he's willing
to die in there yeah it's just a
different animal like that's his ass and
then the heroin but like Bam Bam went oh
wait oh wait I'm [ __ ] really strong
and big oh yeah yeah well Peter said did
you ever have that moment oh I'm really
big and strong like no because I was
smaller yeah smaller heavy weight never
felt that way I was like boy you better
stick and move buddy yeah always always
huh
enough for fighting trash Brown like
that though are we even the same space
Jesus Christ why is he so big I remember
that wide stance he was doing now now if
I was the coach I'd be like we're going
to work on just now here's what we're
gonna do with Travis we're gonna work on
just kicking this part of the attack I
know we're gonna be kicking I want you
just [ __ ] dude just Dutch kicking him
okay
not even turning your body just [ __ ] I
got religious before those fights every
time if I went in before I got out I bet
you did every time I didn't Envy you no
what about you I'd be right there with
you and I was like [ __ ] this I don't
know you
enjoy that I remember Tim Tebow came to
the under Alaska fight and he came to
the you know Tim so they let him oh he
was so nervous you were there too I was
with him talking yeah he came in the
groom before and he was like he's like
Lord he like gave me a prayer or
whatever I was like I'll take it
whatever you got and then my I started
he said are you about to cry I'm like I
don't want to do this amazing you don't
like no he's like Oh I thought you
enjoyed this I'm like Tim absolutely not
give me a job Tim I don't have any
options that's why I'm fighting anything
I want to go out there and fight this
[ __ ] this is as good right now with
hair on his [ __ ] shoulders yeah for
money sir Giant and then go three rounds
and beat him and then get screwed over
by a judge's decision
you think I want that life Timothy
no I don't tough gig but again certain
guys will love that man more power to
them yep
more power to him so do you think you're
gonna go back to church just to button
this church thing out well
I do think it's good it's healthy to go
I I do some praying but uh Church
doesn't count go on Church the
commitment of going to church is always
a good thing every Sunday especially
it's the day you get back I've been like
I bring my baby my new baby maybe my
kids well yeah drag him into it there's
no choice yeah my wife grew up going to
church okay hanging in the choir so
she's she's a Christian
all the time
um no but she will what is that hey man
she grew up doing it every Sunday there
wasn't but what I noticed about people
who grew up that way like at least with
my wife is we're watching stunts and
stuff and she's just like she's so
grounded psychologically some people are
just not complicated she's like she's
just happy she can see the good she's
very good at seeing one thing about your
wife I don't think that's all religious
no I know religious people are not bat
[ __ ] crazy out of their mind where it's
like they'll literally just prey on
things that are going out and doing it
like it's in Jesus's hand like
yeah no go out and do it yeah
do both do both
do both ladies and gentlemen you know
now did you watch any football this
Sunday
uh yeah I'm more into college than Pro
my proteins are off the Broncos are
literally the worst team in the league
damn near
um and then the Rams are the worst
they're tied for the worst team ever to
win a Super Bowl and then this season
they're playing awful uh my boy Cooper
cup is hurt uh is he on is he on Green
Bay still
this is why you shouldn't go to church
because you would you take me to church
you'd walk in uh Cooper cup is the the
white receiver number 10 for the Rams
should win MVP small white guy
um so he's hurt the Stafford's hurt the
the Mis worldwide what's wrong with
charges I don't know either hurt dude
doesn't matter so the the so the Rams
are awful yeah and then charges are
decent they might there's only team here
worth watching yep and my Broncos are
[ __ ] terrible college football's
where it's at right now USC they they
they played UCLA last week one of my
favorite football games of all time and
then they played uh again this week
against Notre Dame beat them and now
they have a chance to be in the top four
for the BCS which is tough to do so
Alabama's out with two losses so you
have Ohio State got the cheeks beat off
them by Michigan just got destroyed by
Michigan so it goes I think it goes um
um who's it chin it's it's the SEC teams
first they're undefeated so you have I
don't Tennessee's up there so you have
Tennessee
you have Tennessee Michigan
TCU for you who the fourth is now
is it the playoffs yeah
my girl's uh my girl's an Eagles fan
Eagles are damn good God damn they're
good that guy Jared hurt is no [ __ ]
joke man yeah he's interesting because
he came from uh Oklahoma right he can
run too he does it all yeah through for
150 RAM for 100 crazy
missionary places Ohio State yeah LSU
Clemson ruined chances keep going down
chin it should give us the list of the
foreign
Georgia Michigan TCU and then the fourth
spot see the fourth spot belongs to
number six USC if they can win the
Pac-12 championship game which stay well
um
so are you more of a college guy or
you're both right now because my team
sucked but then also there's a chance
that
um Deion Sanders is in go to University
of Colorado they offered him the head
coaching gig dude if Dion goes to see
you yeah we going Sizzler really because
he's the greatest recruiter so he got
the top three recruits in the nation his
son's a baller he's at Jacksonville
Super Bowl he's at Jackson State he went
undefeated there so he's like a a big
time get so CEO he's a great coach in
other words I think he's a good
recruiter I don't know how much coaching
he does okay
they're not the only ones that hurts my
feelings
everyone's coming after him I think he's
such a good recruiter and every kid
wants to be like him so they want to go
like he's made Jack and state ridiculous
where's his uh where in the world does
his son play I think for Jackson State
oh wow and his son is quarterback he's
alive Jackson State quarterback
here he says wide receiver oh the top
thing says quarterback I don't know
yeah
we really need him to uh go to see you
but he has an offer from uh South
Florida too and he lives like I don't
know 20 minutes from there and he's from
South Florida well he oh he's only five
seven Bob whoa that's not good for pro
stuff that's why some of you guys who
make it if he has his dad's skill set
he'll definitely make it
yeah but I don't care about him the rest
of the guys that come along with Deion
Sanders man yes
wow oh so there's different songs that
do different ones so this is okay
shador Sanders is six two all right yeah
they're studs uh-huh
but yeah the the Jackson State the pros
yeah Jack states are undefeated the pros
is uh
you know you come to see you you'll see
who's gonna go to the the Big Ten so
you're in a major conference it's a
major school just give me a stopping
ground for Dion he's not gonna be there
you know for 10 years so maybe he's
there for four years turned the
programmer in turns the program around
because it's gonna take about three four
years because they've just been in the
toilet man yes
I mean see you should give him Dow Ward
give him JonBenet Ramsey's old house I
know it's haunted but it's lit you know
like dude you have to whatever it takes
whatever it takes to get him yeah dude I
would literally dude I will massage your
feet man
I will fly every Friday before games and
massage your feet I love it I man I hope
they get Dion they need something dude
the program's been in shamble since I
left awful such a good guy then the
other it's I know they offered Dion they
offered Tom Cable Tom Cable is the coach
at for the Seahawks [ __ ] up they took
his toes off
oh that's right yeah yeah remember the
the Marshall bar stool because he's a
bar stool guy oh man
what happened is Toad I forget but he
posted the surgery weird
um lack of blood flow or something
and he's got already got some [ __ ] up
toes left big toe and second toe
amputated oh why though why did they
there's something going on in him I have
blood clot oh
compartment syndrome yeah Dr deflay
opened his leg to drain the fluids
Sanders layer had his big tone segment
amputated poor guy I mean yeah better
now though than when you're playing
right yes that big one you need though
my big toe's so big it's out of control
really oh my God it is my big toe I'd
wear a size nine if I have that big toe
yeah well that's why he's always on the
thing yeah I don't know how much
coaching he's doing he he'd be up to his
offensive defense coordinators that
really run the program but he just
brings in the recruits that's what we
need to see you man
I pray to God he comes to see you
Yeah Yeah Tim giving a story every day
there
why was he getting blood clots the
[ __ ] going on because we're all
getting old he had a nerve issue with
one of the toes
and then when they did that I guess this
stuff happened they were talking about
taking this whole leg at one point
that's insane no like just the toes
Jesus Christ he's crushing it though
yeah he has a podcast on Barstool gets
paid from them then top you know one of
the top recruited coaches now in the
nation I wonder who else offered them
see you
South Florida I'm surprised Florida
State hasn't although their programs
turn around so they're not going to do
that
it's really to have this after just foot
surgery there has to be some underlying
cause it's more likely not a time bomb
in his leg
you never want to hear that
oh they says toes were gonna die yeah
yeah
well
yeah all right change of some current
events okay
all righty
oh this one
yeah now did Elon post his uh bedside I
don't know for a fact so Elon reveals
what he keeps on his bedside table man
it looks very similar to mine I'm not
gonna lie to you
guns tight Cokes
like golden
um
I really wonder about his um
about Twitter
um and
what happens if [ __ ] Apple and Google
D platform Twitter
it's like is that what we're talking
about here
yeah
what the [ __ ]
well why the hatred for the guy like but
is that a serious conversation I don't
go to elon's Twitter because he talks
about it
D platform but I mean
I mean what's funny is uh
that uh Alyssa Milano who I've worked
with I actually like her but you know
she's kind of crazy on there she um she
actually got rid of my Tesla and bought
a Volkswagen and people like hey you
know Volkswagen's literally started by
the Nazis it's called The People's card
yeah
Apple has reduced so advertising is
different Volkswagen pulled their
advertising too
but he's gonna go through some changes
you know at any time there's something
new you can go through some changes
I mean what what are they why I heard a
bunch of stuff even my older brother
he was saying something like I'm not
going to remember this correctly but he
says I'm like the amount of money
they're they're spending on food at the
Twitter headquarters yes was so insane
because especially the dinner one right
no one ate the dinner so they just kept
putting on that's right neon goes in
there looks at the budget he's like yeah
you dude so you have all those employees
they used to have like really nice meals
he's like well I'm cutting this and
they're saving like I forget how much
100 a month he's like and then he looked
and people like this ridiculous you're
not gonna feed your employees and he
goes no no we have the data that shows
how many employees eat here it's a waste
of money exactly because they're not
they're not eating it was like less than
like 20 we're eating the hot meals so
he's getting rid of that
who else has Apple sensor during code
Apple demand our apps filter some Search
terms
I don't know but he did look at all the
data and he's seeing like what's
happening where's the money going he's
throwing everything off data like look
at this so new user signups that
all-time high on Twitter right now and
then hate speech impressions are lower
you know so it's like this so you got to
be careful listen to the clickbait stuff
I agree so when you go I'm worried about
again I think this is this is like not
real this is there is a war going on
there's just a decision to attack Elon
Musk for what they think he stands but
who's attacking him it's the left right
it's not even it's the extreme left that
are very somehow it seems like people
would you say CNN extreme left because
the the you know they're constantly on
those 24-hour news cycle just [ __ ]
on Elon Musk now remember he's gonna
he's gonna not let them suppress other
opinions yeah right so everyone's gonna
voice and they go well no only our voice
is important he's going no hold on
whether you're left right you got to
Define what hate speech is this is where
we get into real you have a governing
body that decides what hate speech is if
you're using like racial slurs and
threatening people's lives I get it but
overall you have to be careful about you
know because now if you if you say if
your belief is that
um not everybody who's quote unquote
trans is actually trans that would be
considered hate speech well that might
just be me expressing my opinion so you
have to be really careful with this and
that's what I worry about you know well
did you worry about before Elon took
over the suppression of anything not far
left yes that's what I mean so so what
I'm saying is that you know you you once
you get into this this censorship game
you better be careful because you're
going to be censoring [ __ ] but you got
to do something to be fair you got to do
something I say I say let it all fly
unless it's out unless it's downright
harassment which laws against anyway
well that's what elon's saying though
yeah that's that's what he's saying I
believe I believe let it fly in all
sense is the word now the there's one
thing it's possible to to I don't think
it's possible to to
um uh moderate and and it's just not
possible to moderate speech you can't
you can't moderate all of it but what
you can't but what you can't do is
suppress certain views that don't agree
with your political belief which was
what was going on which is insane just
absolutely insane
yeah this apple is also threatened with
whole Twitter from its App Store but
won't tell us why I mean Jesus guys hey
hey Tim Cook
I mean what are you doing man oh come on
honestly you know what they're doing
hard to see that happening though just
because I would instantly like people
make their livelihoods all right what's
going on here Tim Cook
really I mean well I'd love to if you go
to Tim Cook hold on why are you doing
the Twitter off the app store and
because well because Elon he's what no
they there's a he's not suppressing left
he's not suppressing right he's not
expressing the middle of what because
it's not tailored to your political
beliefs you're gonna ban them he would
have to he would have to declare
bankruptcy and Twitter would just become
some old code that would just go away
that's what would happen and that's very
possible no I disagree I think elon's
gonna crush it you think so yeah crush
it um
44 billion dollars is a crazy amount of
money
but I'm I'm with you with this Brian
because there's no way to to have a line
right there's there's no threshold
because at some point it's like where do
you allow this speech to come in and
where you let so if I say I want to kill
you I want to kill your kids whatever
yeah that's easy but then if you get a
little bit further than that like you
know I would love to kill your kids I
would love to kill you or I would want
to uh
but I'm saying that that's illegal
anyway but that's jumping in but that's
jumping into terrorist threat but that's
you know not saying that you would
actually do it I think about example
chin I think if like no I'm doing that
I'm going extreme yeah but even if you
don't but this is where it gets gray
area if you go
if you said something about you know
um
you know if let's say you are on the
left and I said Nancy Pelosi's husband
is gay and that guy was it was a gay
Fight Club situation
now if you suppress that and you don't
let that does that get taken down
because that's not hate speech that's an
opinion yeah so they they get this great
yeah it's hard to find that it's a
speculation it's hard to find that line
that's why it's tough It's a Daydream
but this but this isn't an Elon problem
no I'm not saying this is a social media
problem in general it's just being
highlight because Elon recently took
over Twitter what I'm saying as far as
stopping or just uh taking accounts off
because of what they say like if someone
said something really jacked up like I
want all Koreans to die I want you know
whatever if that's their opinion then
in my opinion I would be like just if
that's that what he wants to say let him
say it and let the public decide whether
I want you know to follow him or talk
[ __ ] to him or whatever just allow
people to say what they want to say well
but but it gets tough but it seems but
what you guys are talking about is like
certain accounts that post this stuff
elon's saying it's freedom of speech
unless it's like that horrible like
death threats but what elon's saying is
right now the algorithm is set up where
if you say something negative you have a
strong opinion on something
well that's why Elon says the algorithm
will promote that stuff so that gets
brought to the top of the feed okay his
new algorithm isn't going to suppress
that where you can't you can't reach a
certain amount of people based off those
hate speeches oh so he's not saying I'm
Banning you because I got you it's not
gonna be highlighted you're not going to
be able to monetize this you're not
going to be rewarded negativity is not
going to be rewarded positivity is which
every app should do okay that's good
then yes
[Music]
these negative opinions this hateful
stuff isn't going to be rewarded on this
platform our algorithms can reward
creative positive things I'm all down
for that then yeah everyone should be
yeah that's good
but his nightstand looks like mine
George Washington gun but I have a gun I
got a gun uh this I thought was super
interesting so before remember
especially Rogan your boy Rogan he's the
one that had people on and they were
saying there's a possible thing that the
whole covet thing came from a lab in
Wuhan in China correct right and we
heard nothing on fauci as far as saying
that's real or not but he was a he was
linked to the lab for some reason right
well he said he said that you know a lot
of these a lot of these viruses in the
past did come from wet markets and a lot
of people don't actually but those are
web markers not the lab right and so so
the idea was it would make sense that
covet came from a wet Market he said
it'd be absurd to think it can't was
leaked from a lab I didn't know that
part but now he's saying he's
open-minded to the possibility that's
happening here now now and plus he's
he's off the board all right connection
again a function of research that might
put his position in Peril that people
were to find out correct things happen
when you do this I've completely opened
my mind despite people so fast
um fashion knows so this was uh knows
that the group of international respect
virologist has written a strong evidence
shows the virus jumped from animals to
humans but said hasn't been definitely
proven has it had any evidence no
whatsoever even when there's nothing to
hide there they had suspicious not
transparent why I thought you said of
the Chinese government that was in 2019
yeah yeah I don't know
um have you seen what's going on in
China yeah the reason is according to
Peter Zeon is that China has had
lockdowns from the very beginning their
population doesn't have does not have
herd immunity and when you do that now
this new strain for us is a footnote
doesn't bother us because we've been
exposed to covet they have it so this
new strain is actually more dangerous
than the first
it's not been exposed and that's that's
why they're coming out because they're
saying hold on not for us not for them
no they're like nobody's dying from this
coveted strain we shouldn't be locked
down well that's probably what they're
saying now which might be true but I'm
saying that's what that's what
scientists said this is really dangerous
for us that's all and so yeah but the
the Chinese public saying we shouldn't
be locked down this new variant isn't
killing anybody no they got locked in
their apartments from the inside
correct that's why they couldn't get out
and they would take children away from
parents and then they would kill dogs
and animals very scary that's what but
this is hey hey this shouldn't be
surprising that is what happens when
when you have top-down command when you
have authoritarian government when you
have one group running everything
there's nothing you can do it's called
tyranny
it's called The Avenues uh
nothing wait so you guys are talking
about something before about letting
people get into your heads and then
being upset at them resentful whatever
yeah I saw this quote not that long ago
and I I thought it was really cool
imagine this if you had eighty six
thousand four hundred dollars in an
account and someone stole ten dollars
from you would you be upset and throw
all of the remaining 86 000 390 away in
hopes of getting back at the person who
took your ten dollars or move on and
live right move on and live see we have
80 86 400 seconds each day don't let
someone's negative 10 seconds ruin the
remaining 86 390 seconds don't sweat the
small stuff life is bigger than that
that's an outstanding I didn't do the
math
that's a great quote [ __ ] great yeah
great and you guys were mentioning
something like that so great quote and
keep that in mind tattoo that to your
[ __ ] back 86 390 or maybe somewhere
you can see it 86 390 86 390 buddy thank
you all right Marcus
yes all right people finding this
interesting oh um a co-founder of crypto
company Amber group dies Suddenly at age
30. so it's just very suspicious with
everything that's going on right now
um you know that that these huge crypto
markets are failing that there's
corruption being exposed and I believe
there's actually a connection between
FDX and handsome
Jesus so
why is there a foul play suspected
all they said was that he
uh that he died suddenly in his sleep
and he's he's 30 he looks healthy he's
not obese so yeah
um
Jesus Christ the digital asset training
platform was made a 4.5 billion such a
smart guy
hmm
so yeah people there's no cause of death
as of what would be the benefit of him
dying though
um he might just have died right it's
the whole crypto thing that's happening
right now now obviously that potentially
could be linked right how the crypto
world is crashing like crazy right now
but I don't know oh man that's a bummer
he looks like he was Asian and Dutch
coolander sounds like a Dutch name
do we know if we got the vaccine yeah
I'll just spitballing ideas there
because we had that previously
all right this one Marcus yes pretty
crazy this is not so I'm seeing this
treading water for 24 hours straight not
to die
dude that's a badass how did he
get
he had been treading water for almost 24
hours on one of the roughest windiest
days
we were the last note out of the harbor
and his last chance of life he was
hypothermic and severely dehydrated but
we got him to paramedics just in time we
found this guy over three is that not
sure how did he end the fell off a
cruise ship thank God I think he fell
off the cruise ship and he was just nice
he must have been the most scariest [ __ ]
he's ever experienced oh my God pitch
black at night yeah I wonder what part
of the ocean he was in not no part
that's good oh yeah nothing you think
once Nightfall comes and it's just pitch
24 hours if you fall off a cruise ship
think about the feet can't touch the
ground it's all the same that's a badass
you have no more hope get him I thought
he fell off a cruise ship but usually
would die right I don't know what that
was uh find out we don't know
he might be a refugee no yeah man is
serious about sleep um
[Music]
cruise ship
24 hours
yeah there you go oh [ __ ]
man was 16 hours later only 15 hours
after fell overboard so it's a different
guy am I mixing two different stories I
feel like a different guy that's
treading for the most recent article so
yeah this one says
Carnival Cruise ship passenger rescued
after spending things in Mexico and
that's him you know a lot of uh husbands
throw their wives around well he fights
to stay above Southwest pass Louisiana
yes the Coast Guard was a lot of
helicopter a lot on a cruise ship yeah
that's why I started putting cameras
there yeah
I gotta get rid of my wife see ya yeah
like not just the Heat of the Moment but
you know fighting on the cruise ship
what's this okay so this can't be good
seven viruses Lane Frozen in the
Siberian permafrost for thousands of
years have been revived and won is 48
500 years old this is a great way to
create a pandemic guys but also just
leave it
well because the thing is when the with
global warming as the ice you're one of
those the permafrost melts those viruses
get a leash you're one of those just
telling you
yeah that virus must be horrible well or
it's just nothing yeah or about an hour
did you guys see that transgender fight
the man fights a man equal rights baby
what happened yeah let's see the uh
video
the transgender man is on the left
oh
[Applause]
oh okay
shout out to the woman who cameraman
fight yeah that's worse
I think the problem there too yeah the
the guy with the with the Muay Thai
shorts on uh is more uh experienced just
looks like a better fighter it could be
that too yeah yeah
but wait is it the uh it's a woman who
became a man or transgender that's what
I'm imagining here equal rights anymore
unless if that if that's God if that
woman became a guy that'd be kinda
that was kind of crazy Hey listen man at
least that at least that bad word woman
slash man or who's now a man is putting
their money where their mouth is it's
like that's not easy [ __ ]
after realizing they were dating each
other online what
Ah that's super interesting now that's
uh awesome why would you divorce her
like after you were into each other
yeah it has me a couple divorced after
discovering they were both having an
online Affair under assumed names
um
they had marital problems that they
secretly talked on an affair online
after some time they both decided to
meet in person only to find out
uh it was them
that means that they do actually dig
each other yeah I feel like you'd bring
you closer yeah be like your chain two
two seven
I've told you things haven't told
anybody before yeah you get divorced
maybe realize that's what I'm saying
something's missing and it's like hey
maybe we should the ending we found each
other online yeah add some more
excitement to your life yeah what are
you doing she's like you're saying some
dirty [ __ ] there you are I don't know
you're into [ __ ] play
[ __ ] I don't know you're into butt play
yeah he's like yeah it's my thing oh
yeah I was just too afraid to tell you
now you know give me that ass oh
it's a really good video so we did this
on shop show but it's good oh yeah so
Patty pumblet uh was walking his dog in
front of a neighbor's lawn the dog took
a nasty messy [ __ ] on the lawn so he
came to the door to talk to the Ring app
and ask if they had any water so he
could clean off the diarrhea his stuff
yeah I'd be like yeah you're trying to
rob my house but hold on hello
out there you're sure to just I feel
like I feel it's terrible you know what
I mean no sorry
thank you very much once again I'm sorry
about that I hate doing stuff like that
that's why I knocked on go on I'll see
you later
all right there it is that's so great is
that Patty the Baddie it is it is
a proper a proper sloppy [ __ ]
Liverpool yeah what do you do a dog
takes a hot wet [ __ ] if you can't really
pick it up my dog did that in a store in
La Jolla in a store on the way in a
woman's clothing store my dog I just
rescued it my dog went my name is Lucy
and I'm gonna [ __ ] here and I'm gonna
[ __ ] here so that you have to throw the
whole store away
what did you do I went uh I'm gonna need
a fire hose I need a [ __ ] space suit
yeah let's go ahead and just burn this
place yeah and I'm gonna need some
Hazmat tape because this is this whole
store's over yes all right chance that
it buddy I think so I got one what I got
one more you finally have a current
event I have a current event I sent it
to your phone all right all right look
I've been getting I got this is this
gonna be terrible I got I up you up you
took you were talking about kamza
chamayev beating Alex pierer I'll never
know how to say his name and as you know
I've already won five thousand dollars
putting my money on pahara I've already
lost five thousand all due respect to
the great Israel out of Samia but Pierre
is just a monster now the question is I
know that we don't know what pajera's
wrestling's about he's been wrestling
with the great Glover Tashara uh he's
got his brown belt
that's a big deal it's not wrestling but
yeah okay so so comes that shamaya
obviously you you were betting on comms
out you said comes out with I said if
they fight yeah that would take him down
within 30 seconds and beat him okay I'm
not saying he beats him in 30 seconds
please uh without a doubt Hamza takes
him down but please I'll say I'm
exaggerating 30 seconds but hanza take
them down yes I think beats him yes
that's not a disrespect to the champ
Alex Pierre stylistically
let's watch that let me watch this let's
watch this clip I want to get who's the
fella who's not keto I don't know I
don't know I don't know who he is from
the ma findings Twitter this just
happened I guess it's just yes this is
yes this is uh
it's from Ariel's show
it's a big dude handsome guy which one
a man oh man they're both all men yeah
I can't wait to see what he's saying
you had dollars okay
number one
translator he said he'll fight if you
realize heavyweight wow right because if
I'm at light heavy weight so bring the
shop I think he was running his mouth oh
you know they're not even gonna
translate
this is incredible he was talking [ __ ]
yeah but Brad I think he said that talk
a lot of crap that she might run over
and blah blah and also he's saying that
he'll be able to take Alex down 30
seconds she might will take him down yes
[Music]
all right so let's let's go let's let's
uh let's keep going that was mean that
was a little too shy
and he proposed to do it back with y'all
he said he went on his mouth fifty
thousand dollars if he beats my head we
both go and those 50k from both sides we
donate
to keep the two innate
also 50 more
that if not do not take him downstairs
so is that 150k I can't 55. I would just
let's just stick it 50 Grand everybody
calm down with the 50. he's thrown
that's a lot
more
if you want to jump on the back
we donate to the to the charity you know
a lot of kids are hungry today's date I
agree
I like for a good cause
and not only to run their mouth
they manage car manager we make an
agreement Christmas is coming let's feed
them
oh that was it you I don't you only
imagine I'll deal with me direct bubbly
go ahead but hero putting his money
where his mouth is first of all I'm
[ __ ] impressed that this guy's
willing to put 50 Grand up of his own
money to prove that chimaya has no
wrestling against Pera that's that's a
conflict I just want the the
the outline better the the translator is
not the best but so it's they would
fight at light heavyweight I couldn't
understand he'll fight a mid light
heavyweight but why would they fight
light heavyweight when huh to my have to
be at his weight because apparently
chimaya is very comfortable at 205.
okay but why wouldn't they fight at 85
for the belt
I don't know
two or five yeah why would you fight at
85 because homicide can fight at 85 yeah
and then he obviously fights at 70 but
he can also entertain I'm sure that Wade
cuts a [ __ ] for pahira but but
here's the thing because there's no belt
there here oh I I see which makes Simon
stupid so here's what I would say
um so so he probably just doesn't want
to cut them he wants he's saying he'll
bet you 50 000 if he loses to chimaya
that's what I'm getting from it that's
got to be tempting for you
[Applause]
at 205 and he proposes to do the BET
with shop
it's fifty thousand dollars
if if we both go and no deal
to the kids in eight I love that he's
doing this for kids I love prahara 15
more oh wait hold on B so he's saying 50
comes from Alex and this translator so
if we both go and those are 50k from
both sides on my side their side we
donate the kids in Aid also 50 more that
Hamza will not take around 30 seconds to
donate charity too yeah we're not gonna
do the 30 seconds 30 seconds that's
stupid obviously I do a show and I I try
to exaggerate I will bet 50k hamzat
takes him down in the first round no
will you bet 50k that comes up Beats him
that's the that's the that's the all day
all right I think that that should
that's the bet that's that's a good damn
just 50k is already a ton damn I'm a bet
man I don't think I can do that because
I don't know I don't know what what
pahara feels like when you grab him
right now you're a wrestler you're a jiu
jitsu guy you've done this a long time
Jiu Jitsu doesn't that much care if
you're that good wrestling I mean
there's no doubt to mine is a better
wrestler than Pera that's very fair to
say I don't think that's a disappear I
don't get how he's offended by me saying
that Hamza style and stylistically these
are just stylistically though that is a
tough matchup from with homthat's skill
set what he does great is a complete
nightmare for Alex yes this is nothing
anybody else isn't thinking or hasn't
said yet I would agree with you 100 now
but if you want the smoke come get it
big boy so you want the smoke if it's
50k are we hearing this 50k that hamzat
beats oxpeare now the only caveat here
it's the the 205 thing is weird since
neither one fights at 205.
you might as well say in and then also
he flies in on a dragon they both fight
it one's at 71's at 85 one's a champ 85.
yeah put your belt on the line put your
belt on put grab 85. oh that's
interesting like why not put your belt
on it if you're so confident no hold on
if you're so confident
that you can do all this to Hamza which
I don't think you can't even have 205
but if you can why would you subscribe
85 you were both 85ers I'm afraid to
take this back because I'm afraid of
both of them I'm afraid of I'm afraid of
pahera who looks dangerous and also I'm
afraid of Brazilians for hating me and
I'm really afraid of chimaya because
he's a Chechen gangster and the Chinese
which I would imagine if you bet against
shamaya if you're also betting against
the dakistanis in a way they're kind of
close even though they have some beef
all things are never again if you do
damned if you don't either way smoke bro
you got to be tempted I know you oh I'm
50. I'm not attempted I'm in you're in I
don't even think about it
my only caveat you're right here first
only caveat here Wyatt 205 when I do
that 85 with the belt online because now
you're you're you're making it cloudy
you're making the division cloudy where
the UFC is definitely not gonna go yeah
let's take our champ and our biggest
star at 70 and have them fight at a
random weight at 205 like it's 19 1993
right we're not doing this weird one-off
well apparently Timaya has no problem
that doesn't matter right you got to
understand the logistics that you see
they're not going to go now do I think
they would do uh uh hamzat verse uh at
85 yes there's a small chance they would
do that depending yeah what they want to
do with Pierre in his next steps and
depending how long is he's out because
he wants to get surging recover
so there's a chance that that fight
could happen to 85. to go to the UFC and
say Hey listen we want to hold up not
only at 70 but also the 85 Division and
do this one-off fight they won't do it
no
I don't know or it's their way of firing
back to me because I said that it's a
bad matchup for him got it I listen the
the business I'm in with Fighters
managers and then comics comics are
sensitive everybody's trying to get more
people you've never met more uh sense of
people than comics and Fighters
really good is that they take it you're
you're sensitive too like you know if
you when you were fighting somebody said
some [ __ ] you'd hold you'd be like
[ __ ] I would never calm out on it
ever yeah I don't know ever different
well anyway I I love that he I this is
very interesting I'm very surprised that
he came at you like this but uh sign me
up like I told you I'll do 100K but the
BET has to be 80 for 100 hold on I know
you're gonna freak out 100K for 100k the
BET has to be at 85 for the belt if the
UFC in some weird world decides to do
this one-off fight at 205 and hold up
both divisions which we know is never
going to happen if that happens then 50k
now this is dumb I just thought of
something this is dumb what this isn't
real
the hair is not allowed to bet
he's not allowed to bet on himself
he's not allowed to
him
hey hey L7 there's ways around that is
there l seven you a square there's ways
around that Daddy no no this is [ __ ]
because he's not allowed there's weights
around that trust me how
my people his people could bet on this
there's a way to do this all right and
it's for charity there's a way to do it
because that's that's how that violation
oh you play the rules that's a violation
of UFC Rules he's not allowed to do that
as a fighter you can't bet on yourself
this is fake he's not been on himself
his boundaries okay but then his
managers people can bet my people
technically and can still okay there's
there's ways there's ways around it the
biggest thing where it's like you're
salivating oh man yeah yeah all day but
the the biggest caveat here is that the
weird one off at 205. UFC's like why
would we hold up two divisions for this
one-off fight and one of you it's gonna
ruin your your your status
yeah you're gonna do 85 for the belt
because you want Hamza to get to about
85 and you can Tinker between 85 and 70.
it feels like Pierre is very very
confident in stopping he shows up this
is the thing I have all the respect in
the world for Pierre this says there's
no disrespect there when I break down
when the homicide asks for the fight
went that's a tough fight for Alex
Pierre and I go man I bet homs I'd take
him down 30 seconds yeah we get this be
a nightmare matchup stylistically it's
not it's not I mean it takes everybody
down really quickly
you know couldn't do anything against
Burns but you know no because he chose
not to every single other fight he
destroys people when he wants to fight
smart
destroys yeah he's a nightmare his
wrestling is bad news for a lot of
people wow I can't believe you broke
that news B I thought you're gonna give
me something like the new book out there
at Barnes and Noble hey I'm just saying
dude wow you're spicy I see what you're
trying to do spicy I'm not spicy I'm I'm
uh Ariel I don't know what I would do
here I give that guy nothing but love no
that's not true you're you you were mean
to him and I'm saying now you're living
in the past too late do it we just
talked about this letting go of the past
they gotta let go of the past
um well is that it chin that's it all
right well there we go [ __ ] hey I'm
glad I I got that in time whoo yeah
speaking of sloppy shits I'll be
[ __ ] in Providence Rhode Island this
Thursday Friday Saturday this Thursday
Friday Saturday children were sold out
baby Providence Rhode Island December
1st through the 3rd that's this Thursday
Friday Saturday the last tour date of
this year so come get some Providence
Rhode Island and then thick boy thick
boy uh MLB quality jerseys sold out but
they're supposed to restock them by
Wednesday I'm told so hopefully they
have the inventory up by Wednesday but
you can still get the hoodies and hats
hoodies are almost sold out as well go
to thickboy.com if you're looking for
that award-winning thick nectar go to
thickboy.com get five dollars off
shipping right now set to your doorstep
son get you something Providence I'll
see you this week all right kids
um uh Naples Florida off the hook Comedy
Club December one two three and four
the Boston Massachusetts Live Boston
December 29 30 31 San Diego California
Mike drop Comedy Club I am there January
five six seven Fort Wayne Indiana Summit
Comedy Club January 13 and 14 I'm taking
12th off so it's the 13th and 14th only
uh I got to change that on the website
Danny of Florida Dania and Brock January
19 20 21 you're up Daddy's working oh
yeah I don't [ __ ] around all right kids
thanks for watching love you we're out